schönen guten Abend Herr Playa schönen
guten Abend Herr Playa ich muss jetzt
mal sortieren denn es gibt so ganz viele
Fragen tatsächlich die sich damit
beschäftigen was die wagnergruppe kann
ich fange mal an mit also kann in
Anführungszeichen wenn man das positiv
sieht im Sinne dessen dass es gut ist
was sie tun sind es wenn Odenthal fragt
über facebook ist die seltene Gruppe
Wagner nur erprobt in der Verwendung
klassischer Kriegswaffen oder auch im
Steuern von Drohnen die Frage stellt
sich heute besonders nach dem
Drohnenangriff auf den Kreml
also das ist zumindest auch deine gute
Frage denn die Gruppe Wagner hat sich ja
auch geändert oder das sagt ja nicht nur
die Gruppe Wagener sondern auch die
gesamten anderen sollten dafür Firmen
die Gruppe Wagener ist nur die
prominenteste Variante davon zu den
Waffen ist zu sagen mittlerweile
benutzen sie auch Drohnen ja
gibt auch gezielte oder die zitierte
drohneneinheiten die diese Aufgabe
wahrnehmen und darüber hinaus gibt es
eben jetzt auch gepanzerte Einheiten die
ganz klassische operationsarten also das
ganz klassische angreifen bzw auch das
Verteidigen wahrnehmen wie eben das
russische Militär auch das einzige wohl
worauf sie nicht zurückgreifen ist eine
unabhängige Luftwaffe
es gibt auch Fragen zu anderen Gruppen
und zwar fragt ein User über Youtube
haben Sie Informationen zu den
gazpromsöldnern und anderen neuen
Gruppen die scheinen ja auch eine große
Rolle zu spielen können Sie dazu was
sagen
ja also die große Grundproblematik
aktuelle ist dass die Gruppe Wagner
alles überdeckt wenn wir in der Debatte
um die Söldnerfirmen in Russland
sprechen eigentlich der große
Zwist in Russland ist aktuell zwischen
dem Verteidigungsminister scheugu und
dem Gruppe Wagner Chef
briochien beide haben sollten Firmen
brigoschen in die Gruppe Wagner und
scheuko eben die Gruppe Patriot die
Gruppe Patriot zum Beispiel ist
rekrutiert sich hauptsächlich auf
Spezialkräften und wird eben auch
dezidiert von dem Verteidigungsminister
darunter unterstützt
aktuelle Analysen besagen z.B auch dass
beide Gruppen gegeneinander sich
ausspielen und auch gerade das auftre
zeugt davon dass die Russische
Föderation auch ein internen Machtkampf
sozusagen auch widerspiegelt das heißt
es nicht dass es präsent Putin betrifft
sondern eher seine Gefolgsleute denn
brigoschin und scheugu haben eine
jahrelange Feindschaft die sie jetzt
anscheinend auch in der Ukraine mit
ihren Söldnertruppen indirekt ausfechten
wenn man so möchte deswegen die ganzen
Gruppierungen werden indirekt auch
normalerweise von anderen
Firmenchefs auch mitfinanziert Gazprom
ist da ein also ein kleiner Teil davon
die in Bataillon Stärke sozusagen was
rekrutieren das heißt das sind meistens
Spezialisten die bei der Verteidigung
eingesetzt werden aber meistens nicht in
der Ukraine sondern eben in Afrika oder
auch ölbohrstation vor von der Küste
Afrikas zum Beispiel
ganz also ganz problematisch ist eben
die Sache mit der Zuordnung wer ist was
denn genau das ist das Ziel der
Russischen Föderation in diesem Umfang
dass man nicht genau weiß wer was und
wann macht und diese nicht zuweisbarkeit
ist eben genau das Ziel
ja der Söldner Firmen wenn man die so
nennen möchte dazu gibt es ein Gedanken
eines Youtube Users mit dem schönen
Namen Hip Hop Guru der schreibt solche
separaten Armeen innerhalb eines Staates
sind für den Staat immer ein Balanceakt
denn wenn sie zu stark werden dann
können Sie sehr schnell die eigene Macht
gefährden das geht so ein bisschen in
die Richtung dessen was sie gerade
gesagt haben zielt aber natürlich vor
allem auch auf die Frage wie gefährlich
können diese Armeen in der Armee für
Putin werden
also aktuell kann man sagen dass es
nicht darum geht dass die Putin
gefährden viel spannender ist ja die
Frage was die Machtkämpfe im in der
Administration
dazu sagen man kann eben auch
Rückschlüsse darauf ziehen wie manche
dieser
Akteure die Zukunft innerhalb Russlands
sehen nämlich dass man eigene
Streitkräfte braucht um notfalls seine
eigenen Freunde in Sicherheit zu
bekommen und der Verteidigungsminister
scheuburg mit der Gruppe Patriot hat
dahingehend einer der größten Streit
machte innerhalb Russlands und eben auch
am besten ausgebildet das heißt
wenn man jetzt mal Blick in die Zukunft
wagen möchte kann es eben sein dass die
Russische Föderation intern schon plant
wie es weitergehen könnte sollte eine
Niederlage eintreten natürlich ist es
jetzt ein bisschen ins Blaue hinein aber
es ist sehr bezeichnend dass sehr viele
originchen und auch sehr viele hohe
Politiker eben private Söldner bzw semi
Streitkräfte in Anführungsstrichen
anheuern um eben sich in der Ukraine zu
beteiligen oder eben auch ihre Freunde
direkt zu schützen
dann lassen Sie uns mal ein bisschen
darauf schauen wer die Menschen sind die
da kämpfen oder in die Kämpfe geschickt
werden hier fragt ein User welche
Nationalitäten haben die Mitglieder der
Gruppe Wagner und können Sie darüber
vielleicht ein bisschen hinausgehen auch
und die Frage beantworten welche welche
Männer in der Regel nehme ich an sind
das
die Gruppe Wagner oder auch die anderen
Söldnerfirmen haben angefangen mit den
Spezialkräften der den sogenannten ksso
das sind praktisch die äquivalente zu
den Navy Seals in den USA die eben
sobald sie ausgeschieden sind ein Beruf
eben gesucht haben und den haben sie
dort auch gefunden die Grundproblematik
ist dass am Anfang als die letzten 15
Jahre das einigermaßen gut funktioniert
hatte dieses Modell denn er in z.B
Afrika sind die meisten Militäreinheiten
schlecht ausgebildet und somit kann man
auch eine gute ausgebildeten Soldaten in
auch einen kleinen geringer Anzahl da
relativ schnell Erfolge erzielen die
Grundproblematik fängt aber an sobald
eben ein großer Konflikt wie eine
Ukraine ansteht dann muss ich auch
andere Leute rekrutieren die eben nicht
diesen Spezialkräfte Hintergrund haben
denn so viele gibt es dort nicht und
bezüglich der Nationalitäten kann man
eben sagen das ist der bunte Mix ist äh
den die Russische Föderation auch bisher
angebracht hat momentan ist aber so so
dass hauptsächlich die Leute rekrutiert
werden die relativ weit weg von Moskau
bzw auch St Petersburg sind das ist
eigentlich so der klassische Ansatz um
eben auch Verluste auf die gesamte
Russische Föderation verteilen zu können
der Vorteil aber wenn man eben diese
Leute rekrutiert ist auch dass man eben
keine Hinterbliebenen Versorgung
gewährleisten muss wie zum Beispiel bei
normalen Wehrpflichtigen oder normalen
russischen föderationssoldaten
nun ist die Gruppe ja auch für ihre
besondere Brutalität bekannt was weiß
man denn über die Führung dieser Söldner
Gruppen über das Menschenbild das
dahinter steht über die Art der Führung
über über Militär
Regeln die dort gelernt oder vielleicht
auch bewusst missachtet werden
also man muss einfach sagen dass diese
Gruppierungen keinerlei Rechtsprechung
unterliegen es gab ja die Fälle in
Syrien wo eben auf grausamster Art und
Weise Menschen misshandelt worden sind
beziehungsweise auch gegnerische
Soldaten einfach massakriert worden sind
die haben zwar in der Russischen
Föderation für einen kurzen Aufschrei
gesorgt aber richtig vorgegangen gegen
diese Leute ist man nicht denn die
wurden einfach nur versetzt intern in
der Gruppe Wagner oder eben in der in
der Gruppe patrio z.B die Frage die sie
raus ergibt ist eigentlich was der
rechts Charakter generell ist denn
grundsätzlich sind diese Firmen
eigentlich in Russland verboten seit
auch ihre finanziellen Ströme aus
agieren
weitergehen ist halt auch noch mal zu
verstehen dass diese Gruppierungen eben
keine klassischen sollten dafür Firmen
im eigentlichen Sinne sind sondern
eigentlich semi staatliche Akteure das
heißt sie sind vom Staat geduldet und
werden auf dem Staat finanziert also sie
generieren keine Gewinne per se um sich
damit neue Ausrüstung oder ihre Leute zu
bezahlen sondern sie generieren Gewinne
für die Russische Föderation selbst das
heißt dir die Begrifflichkeit Söldner
ist da auch ein bisschen zu kurz gefasst
ich hatte eine Frage die anschließt an
das was goline Atay gerade aus Afrika
auch gesagt hat die Frage war von einem
User ob die wagnergruppen gefährlich
sein könnten für die Welt und das ist
jetzt zwar eine sehr global formulierte
Frage aber wenn man sich anguckt was da
in Afrika zum Beispiel passiert dass
versucht wird Demokratiebewegungen zu
stoppen das Diktaturen gestärkt werden
dass man vor allem dort versucht
Gesprächspartner zu halten mit denen man
gute Geschäfte machen kann und man davon
ausgeht dass Demokratien für die Welt
und die Menschen die darin leben
grundsätzlich besser sind als Diktaturen
kommt man dann dahin zu sagen das Wagner
gefährlich ist für die Welt
grundlegend muss man eben auch wieder
sagen die Gruppe Wagner alleine ist dann
nicht der Gefährten der Aspekt sondern
das ist die Russische Föderation in
ihrer Art und Weise eben Einfluss
auszuüben aktuell
denn wie gesagt es gibt einige
Gruppierungen die Welt wird unterwegs
sind und man darf auch nicht vergessen
dass der russische Geheimdienst auch
weltweit operiert wir haben das ja auch
zum Beispiel auch in Berlin selbst
festgestellt bei den Mordanschlägen auch
im Tiergarten zum Beispiel das heißt
diese generelle ja
Drang sozusagen in Stabilität zu
untergraben haben wir beobachten wir
schon seit 20 Jahren die Grund- oder die
die Grundannahme dass die Gruppe Wagen
da jetzt eine gesonderten
Gefährdungspotenzial hat das teile ich
nicht es ist eher eine Gefahr für
instabile Staaten in denen eben kaum ähm
ja Sicherheit herrscht und keine gut
ausgebildeten Truppen vorhanden sind die
aussehen wird die Gruppe Wagen am
meistens also wenn man sich jetzt auf
die direkt bezieht auch meistens direkt
angeworben beziehungsweise eben auch
dort entsandt um die dortige Regierung
bzw eine gewisse Gruppierung zu
unterstützen das heißt sie sind auch auf
die Unterstützung vor Ort angewiesen
also die Instabilität Variante halte ich
auch dahin gehen bisschen für gewagt
weil das eben die us-protokolle sind
Schatz ist aber einer der wichtigsten
verbindenden Frankreichs und Frankreich
unterhält dort eine der wichtigsten
Militärbasen außerhalb der französischen
Republik das heißt
Chat ist eigentlich eines der stabilsten
Länder was das angeht und auch wenn dort
sozusagen die Gruppe Wagen aktiv wäre
wäre dort genug um das auch abwehren zu
können wenn man aufklärt dann eine
letzte Frage noch zum Vergleich zu
anderen Ländern wir haben jetzt viel
über Russland und seine Aktivitäten und
seine seltener drucken gesprochen aber
wenn ich hier in die Chats gucke dann
sehe ich auch zum Beispiel dass ganz oft
von Frankreich und der Armee dort
gesprochen wird und das ist ja auch
andere also von der Fremdenlegion
gesprochen wird Entschuldigung und das
ist das müssen sie jetzt besser
einordnen als ich söldnergruppen ist das
eine die Fremden Legion ist das andere
aber es gibt ja auch andere private
internationale
Militärdienstleister wie sich das so
schön anhört die ähnliche Dienste in der
ganzen Welt ähm tun können Sie das noch
mal einordnen zum Schluss das ist eben
die Schwierigkeit des Rechts Charakters
den eigentlich haben wir mit der
mundkonvention ja eigentlich auch eine
international bindende Erklärung das
sollte natürlich verboten sind
diese sogenannten private military
companies umgehen dieses geschickt indem
sie Dienstleistungen Anführungsstrichen
anbieten
somit habe ich eine Firma die zum
Beispiel eben diese Sicherheit von einer
also von einer erdölfel zum Beispiel
gewährleistet ich habe aber auch zum
Beispiel Angebote einfach dass ein eine
PMC einfach die Küche betreibt in einem
Feldlager wie zum Beispiel auch in
Afghanistan geschehen die Frage die sich
heraus eher ergibt ist wo sehen wir
diese Gruppierungen überhaupt sie haben
ja gerade angesprochen die französische
Fremdenlegion die französische
Fremdenlegion ist Teil der französischen
Armee das sind ja z.B die Gruppierungen
Wagen und Patriot ja nicht ähm und
werden auch nicht eingegliedert die
haben ihre eigenen Strukturen und
agieren außerhalb der befehlsbefugnisse
der Russischen Föderation was das
bedeutet ist einfach dass ich dort eine
Vielfalt an Akteuren habe die das
kommandieren und auch die effektive
Operationsführung einfach vor Ort massiv
gefährden für die Russische Föderation
was eben auch Rückschlüsse auf die
innenpolitische Situation
zulässt ähm wenn man sich aber im siehst
generell anguckt ist es so dass auch
westliche Staaten natürlich
auf diese zurückgreifen weil eben ganz
viele Experten nach ihrer Zeit nachher
aktiven Dienstzeit in solche Firmen
abwandern das ist einfach liegt einfach
momentan